- Greetings everyone I'm Saad Omer,
I'm the director of Yale
Institute for Global Health.
I'm really delighted to welcome you
to the Yale Institute for Global
Health Conversation Series.
In addition to Yale
Institute for Global Health,
which is also called YGH, we are indebted
to the George Herbert
Walker, Jr Lecture series
and international studies
at the MacMillan Center
for International and Area Studies at Yale
for of course sponsoring
this event and the series.
Today's conversation will be focused
on the impact of COVID-19
pandemic on higher education.
We'll cover different aspects of it,
but we will specifically discuss
the pandemic response strategies
taken by university
presidents around the world.
We will also consider how the pandemic
has shaped the future of higher education.
And so obviously they, it was a little bit
of a baptism of fire for
several institutions,
it was challenges that institutions faced
but out of these challenges
come opportunities
and changes for the longterm.
And so this is an
opportunity to touch base
with three prominent university leaders
to discuss some of those things
that will be different going forward.
It is my pleasure to have therefore
three distinguished
guests to join us today.
All of whom are esteemed leaders
in higher education around the globe,
Peter Salovey, who's the
president of Yale University
here in Connecticut, Betsy Bradley
president of Vassar College in New York
and president Firoz Rasul,
president of the AGA Khan University
which is headquartered
in Karachi, Pakistan
but has campuses in
many parts of the world.
Before moving to our
question and discussion,
I will introduce each of our guests
in a little bit more detail.
Peter Salovey is the the 23rd president
of Yale University and a
professor of psychology
he has held several
leadership positions at Yale
since becoming president in 2013,
he has led the development of
new programs and facilities
strengthened partnerships worldwide,
increased access to
Yale College Education,
which is a remarkable goal and achievement
for a university
and enhanced multi-disciplinary
collaborations
and entrepreneurial opportunity
for faculty and students.
During the COVID 19 pandemic,
president Salovey has
been leading Yales efforts
to control the spread of the
virus and mitigates its impact.
Yale scientists and scholars
are conducting research
on treatments, tests and
vaccines for this virus
and helping people understand the science
behind the public health guidance
and collecting and analyzing
data to address issues
like unemployment and vaccine reluctance.
So it's been a 360 degree response
from a university that has
multiple areas of excellence.
Betsy Bradley has served as the president
of Vassar College since 2017,
in that time she has led the college
to establish new programs
and partnerships in India,
Rwanda, and China to bring the model
of liberal arts, higher
education to these settings
and in many parts of the world.
And most recently she
served on New York state's
reopening advisory committee
and help draft the guidelines for New York
higher education reopening
in the midst of the pandemic.
And so it was a pretty daunting task
for university leaders to figure out
how to accomplish their
educational and research missions.
And I think New York was
lucky to have someone
with Betsy's background
as a university leader,
as an educational leader in the state.
Prior to coming, prior to
becoming the president of Vassar,
president Bradley was
on the faculty at Yale
for more than 20 years
she was elected to the National
Academy of Medicine in 2017
and is a member of the
council of Foreign Affairs.
The third esteemed guest
is president Firoz Rasul
he has served as the president
of the Aga Khan University
since 2006, under his leadership,
the university has grown geographically,
but also programmatically
in terms of its impact
and diversity, AKU
which the Aga Khan
University is known popularly
as now operates in Kenya,
Tanzania, Uganda, Pakistan
Afghanistan, and the UK
through its six campuses,
seven teaching hospitals,
300 outreach medical centers
treating more than 2
million people each year.
AKU was teaching research and healthcare
has been transformative
and under his leadership
during the COVID-19 pandemic,
AKU earned its position
as a trusted partner for
two national governments
for innovation and health
and education policies
emergency response, and
clinical trials for vaccines
and therapeutics.
For example, AKU hospitals
were first in Pakistan
and Kenya to treat a COVID patient
to offer molecular testing
and to administer vaccines
on behalf of governments
where AKU is placed,
so, it's my pleasure to welcome
all three of our guests.
I'll start the first round
with a big picture question
Peter, what was the
biggest challenge you faced
as a university president
and how did you respond?
- Well, thank you, Saad
and it's a pleasure to be here
and a pleasure to be
with so many people today
with fellow presidents Firoz and Betsy,
really an honor for me.
And I think it's very
important to emphasize
before I answer the question that while I
maybe the president of
Yale, the team working
on our COVID response was
enormous and committed.
And Saad for example, was on a
call every morning at 7:00 AM
as part of our health, our
public health policy group
by really helping us understand the data
and make campus policy
on the basis of science
and data and many, many many pitched in.
Our biggest challenge in many
ways I think is the challenge
of every college and university president.
And that is to do two things
a massive pivot that
required a multifaceted
changes across the whole university
while not giving up on the idea
that we are gonna continue
our mission, education
and research primarily.
So as we started to hear
about the novel coronavirus
last winter, but before
it came to this country
or to our region, we were already planning
on how do we keep the community
and our neighbors safe.
And I have to say that is
the single biggest challenge, right?
How do we make sure that our university
doesn't become a vector
for the disease in a way
how do we make sure our
local community is safe
but that we're not spreading this disease
through our whole city and
our region and beyond, right?
It's an enormous responsibility.
And then how do we continue education
and research while doing so?
So I would say the biggest challenge
and I'm speaking at a
pretty abstract level here
is balancing these two objectives,
staying safe, keeping the community safe
keeping ourselves from
spreading the virus,
beyond the walls of the campus
while fulfilling our responsibilities
as a major research university.
And as a research university, we knew
that we would need to rely on our experts.
Our experts in public health,
our experts in medicine and nursing.
We knew that we'd get insights
from people in student affairs
and housing and dining.
Just give a couple of examples.
We knew that we needed
to quickly put together
a public health policy group
that I mentioned earlier
an Emergency Policy Group
to implement recommendations
from the Health Policy Group
and people all over the
campus really responded.
So within a couple of months,
well within what a week and a
half of sending everyone home
essentially for spring break,
we were able to pivot to substantially
an online learning environment.
This was thanks to our faculty
who are willing to learn
new skills very quickly
and thanks to a great teaching
and learning center called
the Poorvu Center who
provided coaching and technical
assistance and instruction.
And very quickly, we were
able to reopen laboratories
especially the ones
doing research relevant
to COVID, it's transmission,
it's treatment, it's prevention.
But I would say perhaps the most important
and this will be my final comment
I'm speaking a little
too much at length here
are the most important component
to being able to stay
committed to our mission
making sure that we were teaching,
making sure that our
researchers were advancing ways
to fight COVID-19
vaccinations, treatments,
innovations in patient care.
The most important single
thing that happened
on this campus so far
was that our students and
others adhered to the guidelines
people wore masks,
people social distanced,
people stopped gathering in groups
and that happened immediately.
And it has been sustained for 14 months.
The strongest warnings that we heard
was that particularly
students would not do that.
And you could not trust
your students to do that
and you were there were
editorials being written
that it was unfair for
university presidents
to put that burden on students.
Undergraduates in particular
or late adolescent young adults
they couldn't be trusted to do this.
And we made the decision
that we were gonna trust
our students to do this,
to do the right thing.
We're gonna make it as easy as we could
for them to do the right things
and we were gonna be as clear
as we could communicating
what needed to be done.
But at the end of the day
we were gonna trust our students,
I don't want to be
president of a university
where I can't trust our
students to do the right thing.
And I'm glad we did.
It may have been the single
most important component
of all this to answer the question,
the part of this that was the single
most specific challenge.
And I'm just grateful and
proud that our students
and our community as a
whole did the right thing
and continues to do the right things
in response to the threat of the virus.
- Excellent, before I
go to the next speaker
I would remind that
people have the ability
to sort of ask questions
that we will sort of channel
towards our speakers,
our panelists in a while,
after we sort of get through
the first part of the section
a lot of you are following are
watching it on Facebook live.
And so there's a way to send
questions through that as well
and so I appreciate
everyone staying engaged.
Betsy you're leading an institution
that had a few unique
assets, it's location,
it's student body
and a president who had a
public health background
any specific insights, again,
in terms of the big picture
that the biggest challenges you've faced
and anything you you'd like to share
that university leaders can
learn from your experience
and your unique vintage point.
- Thank you, Saad,
I really appreciate being invited
and Peter was so nice to imagine
and think back to what Yale
was like so congratulations
to everything you've
been able to accomplish
in these last treacherous 14 months.
Just maybe a little bit of orientation.
We have about 2,500
undergraduates at Vassar
a faculty of three to 400, 300
people, about 1200 employees.
And we stayed open through the
whole pandemic and still are.
So we have about 85% of
our students are on campus
taking classes in person
as many faculty wanna
do some kind of hybrid or
there are students remote
so, and we have a ton of tents around
so, ultimately depending on the weather
the classes are 50/50
in person or not remote
in the fall it was more like 70% in person
when it was nice and sunny.
And I'm hoping to see that again, this May
so it's been quite a ride
and I think looking forward
and looking back the
question you had posed to us
what is the biggest challenge?
I actually think there are a couple
that happened really early on.
The first biggest challenge was to screw
up the courage to say, we're coming back.
And I remember the exact
senior team meeting
when I could see a path
towards how we could actually
house students on campus.
And I was working with the New York State.
So I knew it would be, by the guidelines.
But I remember saying to people,
look we have to decide now
we're coming back or we're not
you can't decide that
in a month and a half.
It has to be now.
And we're gonna have to
plan every single minute
for the next eight weeks
to be able to do this.
And our team like said, okay, let's do it
so that was a brilliant moment.
And then I would say the second thing
that occurred is very soon after that
is we set our values.
We had a long meeting
about what were our values
and our values ultimately were
to protect the most vulnerable among us.
So no matter what we did
we were going to either
the financially vulnerable
or the medically vulnerable,
or maybe isolation vulnerable
socially vulnerable, that was job one.
And our second value was equity.
Everything we did, we
tried to do equitably.
So if we're gonna allow
the athletes to do this
we had to allow the rest of
the non-athletes to do that.
In other words, the
context would be one where
we could be as equitable as possible
and in all of campus response.
And then like Peter, and we said
our third value is our mission.
We provide the highest
quality liberal arts education
and inclusive and diverse setting.
And we're gonna keep that mission alive.
So setting those values
ended up being fundamental
to everything we did.
And then I would say the largest challenge
which was similar to what
Peter said was culture change.
How do you get 2,500 students to decide
yeah, they're gonna be
not socializing with
each other the way they used to
not gonna eat indoors with
each other for awhile,
all of the various pieces.
And how do you calm down the parents
who are very nervous about
the fact you're gonna do this.
And that culture change really
came through a mechanism.
We call the Vassar Together
which was about a 40 person committee
of faculty, students,
staff, administrators
coming up with what
would the guidelines be?
And we tried to use harm reduction
what were guidelines we could live by
what were things we would say,
we can actually hold
everybody on this campus
and if we do that
then maybe they don't need
to be so careful masking
because they're not
getting exposed outside
once we know they're negative.
And honestly that worked,
it was and still works.
I mean, even now that we're
more vaccinated than we were
we're constantly looking
back at these to say, okay,
well can people go into town now
or can we have class inside
of the normal density
all of those now go through
the Vassar Together group.
And if there is any sort of
obligation of the expectations,
we also have a large group
called CCT that actually
reeducate, does restorative justice,
does do some referral to
student conduct if there issues
so, those structural pieces that we put in
I think they were challenging.
I guess the culture
change was the challenge.
And I think those structural pieces really
helped us achieve it at least so far.
But look I'm still learning everyone else
so don't tell me to teach others.
I wanna hear what Firoz
and Peter have to say
and learn from that so we can
continue to be healthy and safe.
- Great, wonderful.
So Firoz, AKU has this unique
role in multiple countries
as the premier sort of
healthcare, teaching institution
and also as increasingly
in other fields as well
and especially in education
and media, et cetera
any thoughts from that perspective
that the biggest challenges that you faced
as a university president
and how did you respond?
- Thank you very much
Saad for this invitation
and it's fascinating
listening to Peter and Betsy
to see here their experiences
in the last 14 months.
As you pointed out,
we are in multiple countries.
And the first thing that
we had to figure out
for each of our countries,
what the government was doing
and remember our governments
are all in the developing world
and they initially were not sure
about whether they should lock down
whether they should allow
continued engagement
or interaction of people.
And they were sending out
signals on what schools
and universities should
do, public transportation
and so long lock downs on
shopping and other areas.
And the lock downs were much
more onerous than anything
I think we've seen in the US or in Europe.
And so we were trying to navigate our way
through that to say, how do
we keep the institution going
while we try and work with the rules
and regulations from the local governments
and even and even those
rules were changing
almost by the week as
they were learning more,
as all of us were learning more.
So that was our first challenge
in trying to figure out what we could
and could not do in each of the countries.
Borders were closed so we have
movement between countries was curtail.
And that also affected our
faculty who used to travel
between campuses or within the country.
So that was the first
thing we had to adjust to.
The second thing that
I would say that being
as an international university
is how do you now come
up with a set of common
goals or values, as we've heard
that we are going to
adhere to and practice
while complying with national
in multiple countries requirements.
And so that was a big challenge for us.
And we had to figure out
how to do that and one way
I guess it was more by the
invitation of the government
than by any deliberate strategy by us
was we were appointed on
all of the advisory groups
that each government had set up
to help them make policy
decisions through this process.
So we had our faculty, our researchers,
our administrators on several
committees with governments.
And so we were able to
influence shape or inform,
look if you do this, then
this is the consequence,
if you do that, then
maybe we can adjust this
and be more flexible in some areas.
So that was the second challenge.
And I think the third
for us as a university
because we are a private,
not for profit university
in the developing world,
most of our income that we
support other than tuition
comes from either donations
or comes from the income
of our hospital, the seven
hospitals that you mentioned
around the countries where we are,
and immediately what happened
was as COVID came about
the non COVID patients
disappeared, they just evaporated.
And that was our income
and we need to figure out
how are we gonna keep
going without the flow
of funds coming in from our
hospitals and healthcare system.
And that was a big shock
to the whole system.
And I think Peter used
the word massive pivot,
I think massive is an understatement,
I mean, the pivot that
we had to figure out
is how do we not only keep
going with the education side
but also how do we continue
to run the hospitals?
Because people wanted care,
they wanted to come for tests,
they wanted to know whether,
this fever they have
or this cold they have is
not something more serious.
And I remember one day in Karachi
our hospital was full emergency was full
and we had a group of 2000 people outside
trying to get into the hospital.
And we had to get the
police to stop the people
from rushing the campus and
the campus at the hospital
is also where our academic facilities are.
So the students couldn't go in and out
people couldn't go in and out.
And this panic set in about,
what's gonna happen to me.
And of course it affected our staff
and it affected many of our faculty
and doctors and nurses who
were all trying to provide.
So we were on the one hand trying to teach
and keep that going, on the other hand
trying to make sure that
we kept our facilities open
for those people who needed care.
And thirdly was trying to figure out,
well how do we actually
get some funds out of this?
And that was our biggest challenge
and it continues to be, although
some of that is stabilized
we've figured out how to separate between
our facilities, our
campuses, our hospitals,
those patients that come for COVID
or COVID testing or COVID treatment.
And those patients that come
for non COVID health care
and how we can continue to
give them the confidence
that we will keep you safe,
you will get treated for heart disease
or diabetes or cancer,
whatever else you have,
and that we will help you continue
to get recovery from your disease
and make sure you're not
gonna be infected with COVID.
So for instance, every
patient that comes in
we test them for COVID just to make sure
that they're not carrying
something asymptomatic.
And then we know we're dealing
with a different problem.
And so we figured out a protocol
a system where we're able to do this.
And the last thing I would say
before we open it up to questions
is we set up a global response team,
we call it the GRT, we meet once a week.
We used to meet once every two weeks
probably go back to once a week,
depends on the we're on the third wave
in our countries right now
so we will have to adjust.
And the biggest challenge
that we're facing,
not just the fact that we have
increasing number of patients
but what are we gonna
do about vaccinations?
You mentioned that we are one of the few
government vaccination sites
but you're talking about very few vaccines
because most of the vaccines
that come to the countries where we are
will come from Covax or this facility
Gavi set up facility and Covax by gets all
of its vaccines from the
serum Institute of India
which has stopped shipping.
And we don't know when it's gonna resume
so the lack of vaccines in
the countries where we are
is a massive problem, it's a huge problem.
So for us, going back
to some sort of normal
or some stability is
still not on the cards.
It's not in our vision
because we just cannot
see when our students and
others will be vaccinated.
The best we've been able to do
is vaccinate some of our
frontline healthcare workers.
But other than that this
is an ongoing challenge
that we will face for
the foreseeable future
until we see some solution
to vaccinations for other countries
outside the Western world.
And we see solutions that
we figure out how to live
with COVID in all of
its different variants
and manifestations over
the next period of time.
I'll stop here now
- That's a really good point you raised
and if I may comment on that
as someone who has
spent most of his career
on vaccine research, I think we,
as a world we have to do better
in terms of getting the
vaccines out to countries
where the outbreak is not
gonna be over in a few months,
the prospects of things
getting under control
for higher education, for our countries
like the US are high, even
with the variants, et cetera.
But with the inequity
in vaccine distribution
is going to impact, continue
to impact higher education
and the broader society going forward.
So I think as academics as
institutions and as students
I know that a bunch of
students that usually
sort of watch our events
in this conversation series
it is our responsibility to be advocates
and problem solvers with our partners
in low and middle income countries.
Switching to another sort
of round of questions,
Peter, what changes have occurred
that will strengthen the institutions
like Yale moving forward, particularly,
how it engages with the rest of the world.
- Yeah, thank you for that question,
first of all, I would say
that our worldview has
changed as a result of COVID.
We more than ever recognize that we have,
we are citizens of the world
and we have obligations to the world.
Once again, we are, what COVID
has done is make the question
of disparity of inequity,
so salient to us.
And I think we can all
know that intellectually
but as the epidemic, as
the pandemic unfolded,
where, who, what communities
were affected most severely
what individuals had the
most severe outcomes.
And now, as we have vaccine
where is the vaccine being distributed
and where isn't it, right?
So we as institutions of higher learning
we have to recognize
that we can play a role
in promoting inequalities,
promoting disparities in health
or we can play a role where
we're part of the solution.
And I think going forward,
we need to be thinking
and I know most people
share this view in principle
but we may need to be
thinking about how to do that
how to reduce disparities in
our own society and globally.
Now you asked me the
question, what changes have
occurred that would strengthen
institutions moving forward
particularly how they engage in the world.
I think we have become much more nimble
as a result of dealing with the pandemic
at working across boundaries
and at collaborating, right?
The value of collaboration
has never been clearer.
And that happens at multiple levels.
So our administrative structures
find people no longer in their silos,
no longer not talking to each other
but working with each other every day.
The number of people who worked,
who have been working for 14 months
with someone they didn't even know
prior to the pandemic is huge, right?
The number of faculty working
across boundaries and disciplines, right?
So the people modeling the epidemic
working with those developing vaccines,
working with with economists
about how to deliver vaccines
right, much more integrated
approach to solving a problem.
And of course, a more global perspective
on how that problem needs to be solved.
No one person, no institution
no nation can solve a
crisis like this on its own.
I think that the crisis
has really accelerated
our understanding of
the need to participate
and engage in multidisciplinary teams
and international partnerships.
Can you give me just one example?
It's a small example, but it's important.
So since the start of the pandemic,
the results of thousands of
not yet published studies
from around the world relevant to COVID-19
have been generating right findings
from thousands and thousands of studies
tens of thousands probably.
Well, how do we make sure there's a way
for everybody to benefit
from those findings?
Well, Yale partnered up
with Cold Spring Harbor Labs
and BMJ actually to create
something called med archive.
And it's a pre-print server
for health-related research.
And this is a small contribution
but it really allows
scientists to share data
and insights across boundaries
of discipline across boundaries,
across national boundaries.
And it can dramatically accelerate
the search for treatment
the clinical treatments,
the search for vaccines.
And I think it's a good example
of how do we build networks, platforms,
ways of working across the world
that break down barriers that historically
have stood in the way of progress.
I think universities
play a particular role
in their ability to convene
their ability to create such platforms,
their ability to work in
a less politicized context
than our governments can with others
like-minded others around
the world in addressing
something like a pandemic,
but other kinds of global crises as well.
- I think that's a great point,
go moving to, moving on to Betsy.
So there's been sort of give
you an audience question
and there's a lot of discussion
of keeping campuses safe
at least in the US and
fall through vaccination.
Do you think requiring students,
and that's the question
from one of the audience members,
do you think requiring students
to be vaccinated will become
a norm on college campuses,
at least in countries where
the vaccine is available?
- Thanks for the question
and I saw that in the Q
and A and nice to see you
since I know the person who asks,
I think it's too early to tell
that certainly is our approach at Vassar
that students will be
required to be vaccinated,
however, they will be able to opt out
if they have medical reasons
or religious reasons,
there's always a path off
but we'd like to get ourselves to,
95, 98% of our students are vaccinated.
And I think that that is
really an important piece
and it ties very well
to sort of this larger
culture of we proceeds me,
we've worked on that hard at Vassar.
And I do think at this time
students get that getting
vaccinated is part of that
Maybe they're nervous about it
but I think at the end of the day
they're gonna privilege
their more social environment
than their own individual view on that.
We did in fact, yesterday
have a clinic here
and vaccinated 450 people.
So that was really exciting,
again working with the state of New York.
And I hope that we'll be able
to do that over the long haul.
- I just wanna quickly say,
I completely agree with Betsy
and we need to, we need our
students to be vaccinated.
We're gonna, we're
working very hard to get
vaccine available to them in an easy way.
And it's probably too early to answer
the mandatory question,
but I definitely lean
in that direction quite strongly.
- Great.
- Good to hear that.
- So I'm so glad as a vaccine researcher
and that someone who has
contributed to vaccine policy
I'm particularly happy
to see a bunch of vaccine
related questions.
So the next question is to Firoz
especially given sort of a
huge role in policy, et cetera,
how can universities all across,
but deal with misconceptions
regarding vaccines
around the world in
countries where you work
and how can institutions
of higher education,
especially with a strong health component,
convince people that these
vaccines are safe and effective.
This is another audience
questions, as I said, yeah
- Alright, that's a difficult question
is I think at any part of the world,
but certainly for us vaccine
hesitancy or reluctance
has been a fact of life for many years now
as you are aware, all the
different types of vaccinations
for children that require
have been a challenge
for countries like Pakistan
and East Africa polio vaccinations
they've been a big challenge as you know
that Pakistan is one of the few countries
that still has cases of polio
and the vaccinations campaigns
have been mostly successful
but not entirely successful.
And the reasons vary
from social, political,
clan to I'm not sure I would
agree that in our countries,
there are religious reasons,
They may be people who take
advantage of or use religion
as a reason for people
not to get vaccinated.
So the issue of vaccine first
for us, it's availability
as we mentioned, once we
have vaccine availability
then we hope that
we're able to vaccinate as
many people as possible.
The challenge is going to
be access to remote areas
where our populations live.
And then once you get
to those remote areas,
working with the clan leaders
and the tribal leaders
to have them agree that that village
will be vaccinated or not.
And vaccinations have had a history
in parts of the world where
we work, which will make it
I think a challenge that we are gonna have
to work with governments,
work with social groups
work with village communities,
with civil society
to be able to get people to
become much more comfortable
that they will be able to accept vaccines.
The issue also as you know
Saad as a public health expert
in the first wave in
the second wave perhaps
Africa and Asia were less effected.
If you look at the rates
and people said it was the demography
much younger population,
it was innate immunity
because they live with
pathogens all the time.
I mean, there were lots of
theories that are out there.
So people have the sense that,
well it's not gonna affect me
this is a disease of the West
that's where it's happening.
We, those of us who live
in the developing world
are not really gonna be as
affected as those elsewhere
but that's beginning to change
if you look at what's
happening in India right now.
And if you look at some of the
countries of Africa as well
South Africa being one, Kenya,
which is where we are based
we can see a massive
surge in the third wave.
And so obviously the
something is changing,
it is a variance or changing it
or some other factors are changing.
So this smugness, if you like about,
we don't need the vaccines
is going to disappear very quickly
so it's sort of a long
answer to your question
but I think it's gonna
take multiple inputs
and multiple players and multiple factors
to be able to convince
people to be vaccinated.
- Great, so the next question is Peter
I'll ask you the question
and others can chime in
it's from from Dean Sten
Vermund, who's the Dean
for those of you who don't know
he's the Dean of Yale
school of Public Health,
is a very prominent
public health professional
and has contributed substantially
to the pandemic response
during this pandemic as well.
So he, obviously his
initial comment is that,
he congratulates the universities leaders
for making their respective
communities safe,
but his question is that there were a lot
of parallel efforts that
happened at each campus.
Is there a way to come
up with SOP approaches
that can be shared across
different universities,
at least different
classes of universities,
different categories of universities
based on their size, location
and the composition of
student body, et cetera.
So maybe Peter, you can start
and if others wanna chime
in that'd be great as well.
- Sten, I thank you for that question.
And I think there are
informal efforts to do that
but I think the general goal
of trying to write the
case study and develop
the standard operating procedures
for the future is a very, very good one.
I'm part of a few of the
networks that Yale is a part of.
So the Ivy League presidents get together
on a pretty regular basis.
And there's an incredible openness
about sharing our experiences with COVID
the AAU which is a group of
university research universities
it's primarily US and
that group gets together
and talks among itself
sharing information.
So I think that'd be great to step back
and try to write a
playbook for the next time
there's certain it's
very interesting, right?
Cause there's certainly
lots of general principles
that we can develop.
I think one of them is
listening to experts,
respecting science
I'm thinking at the most
general level, right?
Listening to experts, respecting science
acting congruently with
for us the guidance
from the state of Connecticut,
guidance from the CDC.
Having said that there also
is a lot of local variability.
Betsy was giving the example
they are in a fairly
rural part of the state.
I mean, there's an
important town near them,
- Wrong, careful.
- You have a small state,
you have a small city
and then a larger rural catchment
area, I guess I would say.
But every campus is a little
different is all I'm saying
and even when I talked to
the Ivy League presidents
what can be done, let me
not make it so personal.
What could be done at Dartmouth
sitting in Hanover, New
Hampshire was very different
than what could be done at Columbia
sitting on the upper
West side of Manhattan,
just to use more more pointed examples
or more obvious example.
So yes, I think we can write
the standard operating procedures.
And I think step one is going
to be listen to our experts
listen to our scientists,
respect the modelers
and the like but then
there is going to have
to be some variability
across institutions too.
- Great, that's I think
that's an important
set of principles for perhaps
other crises as well, I
guess, other than pandemics
and so on and so forth,
Betsy, switching to
international collaborations,
and it's sort of, any
thoughts on how COVID pandemic
has played a role in
connecting universities
around the world and how
universities can effectively
and strategically create
learning networks.
So that's another question
from our audience.
- Yeah, and I agree with
what Peter had just said
about local networks being so important
but let's take it to the higher level.
What I've sort of witnessed
during this pandemic is the, and again
this is very much reflective of Vassar
and Vassar sort of deep
commitment to the liberal arts
and multidisciplinary thinking
and sort of critical thinking
what I've really noticed is
universities around the world
that are just dipping their toes
into what really is liberal arts.
And particularly I'm
thinking of the university
of Global Health Equity in Rwanda,
which I started working
with when I was at Yale,
but we continue to at Vassar
or the university of Liberia,
these are places that are really working
to develop a medical care system
and a healthcare system that
can prevent future pandemics.
And what are they asking for?
They're asking for some
courses that prepare people
in the areas of the liberal arts
meaning critical thinking humanities,
thinking about it's not
just the medical approach
to the vaccination and
the dealing with COVID
but the thinking more
broadly about humanity
and how history can teach
us how we might want to
deal with these things in the future.
So what I find interesting
is whether we will ultimately
have more international
collaborations where we're trading
what each other knows
in the case of Vassar
I think we're very well versed in the area
of liberal arts and the
pedagogy that goes with that.
And I actually think
the pandemic has shown
how important those sort of out of the box
thinking skills are the same time,
as Peter said, we're in
one place in New York
and it also we learn a
lot from being engaged
internationally of what what others may
maybe prioritizing, et
cetera, so I think it's opened
up opportunities to tell you the truth.
Plus we're all used to zoom now,
so it's so much easier to have conferences
and just this event, it
was a 10th of the price
that normally would be to
fly everybody in and whatnot.
So I think we're really galvanizing
that kind of collaboration internationally
and it will amplify over time.
- Wonderful, Firoz, AKU played a role
a very interesting role in
quickly building capacity
in healthcare providers in countries
where it will work so through, for example
building capacity for critical care
or sort of patients who
require critical care,
even when it's not available
and quickly up scaling,
scaling gap undergraduate
education online, et cetera.
So any interesting perspective
of using these online platforms
that can outlast the pandemic
that were built up fairly quickly
both in terms of the
university's core mission
but as its expanded mission
to build capacity in a crisis,
especially in a situation
where internet access
is not uniformly available.
- So two parts to your
question, so the first one
I would just want to
broaden it a little bit
and maybe pick up on the
international collaboration
question you pass on to Betsy
in parts of the world where we are Saad
one of the lessons for us
during COVID was the following.
As soon as the pandemic hit
we couldn't buy PPEs, cause
countries stopped exporting them
there were rules that
said you can't export
you couldn't buy therapeutics
because countries were stopping people
their companies from exporting
it, you can't buy vaccines.
And we realized in the developing world
we were at the mercy of
the generosity of others
and the international, the
WHOs and other systems,
Gavi, Covax while well-meaning
had limited ability to make a difference
in what I just described.
So it became very clear
to us very quickly.
We are going to have
to build local capacity
to be able in research in therapeutics
in understanding treatments
that work locally
but that autonomy that independence
from all the reliance
on the lack of reliance
from other international players
was something that came
hit home really hard.
And this is something
we are thinking about
and it will shape what this
university, our university
and other universities
in parts of the world,
where we are what they decide to do
and where they decide to put
their focus as we go forward.
As far as the issue of, as you said,
going to online learning in countries,
where there is a challenge
of the availability of the internet.
We've pivoted very quickly,
we were very fortunate,
we started a teaching and learning center
or network very early
it started to look at hybrid learning,
blended learning, asynchronous learning
because of the sheer number
of countries we were in
and the dispersion of our student body
and faculty for that matter.
So we had already started
to train our faculty
in thinking about this,
but when the pandemic hit
it was a very sudden, I think Peter used
the word nimble, agile
would be other words,
we had to be extremely agile to switch
and start teaching our faculty
about creating materials
that they were using for
face-to-face teaching,
for online learning.
And the population of students
didn't know how to learn online,
they'd never done it before.
So we not only had to train the faculty
we had to train the students
and the students many of whom were remote
either had limited internet
access or intermittent.
And the one thing that in
the West we take for granted
that we don't have in our
parts of the world is power.
We didn't have electricity.
So why we said to the students
you need to go home and we'll,
you learn from home and they would,
there was intermittent electricity.
So all of these challenges
are continuing for us,
and within that, we are
trying to make this work.
Now we were able to give devices to,
because of donations and
generosity of people,
to our students so they
could actually have a device
like a notepad or a computer
from through which they could access.
And that was as basic as
that we had to deal with.
But I'm happy to say that when you look
at the results of our
students after 14 months
although they didn't,
the academic year was
longer cause we had to stop.
We are encouraged by
the results that we see
although Peter's point is very important,
it's not the same.
We are seeing that the
experience is not the same
of people who are learning online versus
in among classmates, among
others, among faculty.
And so that is something
we are trying to figure out
how we can create that environment.
So people feel that the
experiential learning
is an equally important part of content
that we see that comes
through online learning.
- We have another
question from the audience
and it's about teaching
and learning centers.
And Peter Poorvu Center at Yale
have played a hugely important role
in sustaining our activities
our quality of education, et cetera
but going forward and thinking,
building on our experience
and this question comes from
professor Tashman Cormen
who is a leader in curriculum development
and quality in teaching,
et cetera, outside Yale.
And so what lessons can we share
in terms of the value of
teaching and learning centers
not just in pandemics, et
cetera, but beyond that as well.
- Sure, we have a wonderful teaching
and learning center at Yale
called the Poorvu Center.
And in a matter of two week
spring break, last March,
they offered classes
small group workshops,
and one-on-one tutorials
to essentially all the faculty teaching,
especially Yale college students
and getting them comfortable with zoom
and teaching on technology.
We weren't optimizing at that point,
we were just trying to help people
make the transition quickly,
but what has happened over time
as both people have
become more comfortable
is a lot of creativity
around teaching online.
And again, these teaching
and learning centers
can be a source of best practice
around collecting these innovations.
So I have a brother who teaches theater
he teaches acting online and he said,
well, I teach acting for the stage,
but actually zoom lets
me talk a little bit
about what happens when you're in front
of a camera and television
acting, film acting, right.
So he adopted, he changed.
My wife teaches maternal and child health
actually at a state
university here in our region.
And there, she had the challenges
of students who didn't all have broadband
students all didn't have easy
and comfortable and isolating
learning environments
and learn to change her classroom teaching
in a way that kept them involved
created more active learning
so that the passivity
of not having your classmates around you
or the lack of social facilitation,
didn't weigh too heavily.
So our teaching and learning
centers can be wonderful
repositories of collecting knowledge
about what works and what doesn't
and then be great
resource for our faculty.
Just one more point while teaching online,
teaching through zoom, teaching remotely
in my view will never
replace classroom instruction
while places like Yale
and places like Vassar
will continue to be oriented
around in-person instruction
primarily boy, did they
create leverage for all of us
boy do they create the
potential for greater reach?
I'm a psychologist and
there's an expression
that psychologists like to
use came from a president
of the American psychological association
which is how do we give psychology away?
Well, I think a lot about how do we give
without compromising our mission,
without compromising our financial health
how do we give more of Yale away?
And we can give more of Yale away through,
the magic of zoom and
we do, and we'll just
in the kinds of situations
that Firoz mentioned.
Just one other quick
thought, how are we all gonna
do our work differently
now that we have become
now that we as administrators have become
more comfortable on on zoom
is my carbon footprint
going to be as large
with all the traveling that
university presidents do
traditionally is it going to be as large
as it once was when I can get together
with Firoz and Betsy for a meeting,
on zoom without driving to Poughkeepsie
or flying to Pakistan or
Kenya, or what have you, right.
I did grow all, get it,
I think we're gonna do business
in a lot of different ways.
And our teaching and learning centers
are gonna be the one of the places
that picks up on helping
us figure that out
not part of their traditional mission
but they're gonna help us
figure out when it works,
when it doesn't.
- So a couple of sort
of last brief questions
from the audience starting with Betsy.
I think there was a very interesting
and thought provoking question about
physical challenges in
accessing healthcare
and what institutions have learned
in this a crisis situation,
about people helping people with
that have trouble accessing
their surrounding communities,
et cetera in the healthcare setting,
Betsy you have thought about
and worked on these kinds
of issues for a while.
- Yeah, I think it's an
incredibly interesting
and important and unexpected that for us,
the pandemic made all
of us unable to access
what we used to be able
to access so easily.
And in a way, I think it
really leveled in some ways
leveled some playing
fields around the campus.
There wasn't walking a lot
of classes could be online,
people could access that better
closed caption on everything.
We worked on see-through masks.
So people who couldn't hear
could see the lips still
and it was, it has been sort
of an amazing experience
because I think now
everybody understands better
what disability could be
and what it could in
fact result in your life.
As a result we just started
a very high level committee
on accessibility and are
starting to put together
a much different approach of
how do we make our environment
accessible for everybody.
And I never would've thought
the pandemic did this
but again, it brought us sort
of, we proceeds me approach.
It made us, I think, more
understanding of each other
and our different abilities,
so I'm hopeful for the future on this.
- So Firoz I'll give you
the last brief question,
which is what is the future
of international collaborator
collaborations for this pandemic,
which is not nearly over
in many parts of the world.
It's not over in any part
of the world, but it will
it is likely to go on longer
in many parts of the world
and beyond what is the
future of collaboration?
- I think the pandemic has shown us
that this is not a local situation.
Something that happens in one part
of the world now gets traveled
very quickly to another.
And that's become pretty obvious
to the I think everybody involved.
I think universities have a
very important role to play
in terms of bringing
together people to start to
address some of these
problems, which are now common.
We all, that's what we have seen.
I don't think our governments
have set a good example
as I said earlier so far.
And so I think we need to work
beyond what the governments do not within
and or wait for leadership
from the governments
because they have other priorities.
They have other constituencies
that they have to satisfy
but I think there is an
even more opportunity now
for collaborations on
vaccines, on new medications,
on treatment and in some
ways the pandemic has leveled
the playing field that
you use the expression
that Betsy just described.
We have done clinical to
undertake in clinical trials
in Pakistan and Kenya,
on Chinese vaccines,
on other vaccines, French
vaccines and so on.
And we've contributed to the data
on phase three trials and
understanding of certain
populations or certain ethnic groups
and so that's certainly been
part of our contribution
and no reason why we can't also work
with other institutions in
developing common standards
common solutions and common areas
joint research is beginning to flow.
And the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
has been very strong in supporting this
and we are recipients of their grants
and we're very grateful
for some of the work that they support,
but we're not the only ones.
And working with the
University of Michigan
or University of Washington
or doing work in these areas
I think we began to demonstrate
how much more it's possible.
- Yeah, and Yale.
- And Yale, I should just
say while I have a minute
that our first collaboration
was with the Yale
I don't know, the hospital,
the New Haven Hospital
when we started, they
were describing to us how
they were dealing with this
because we were 60 days after
in terms of our search
that happened in New Haven.
And they really helped us understanding.
There was one thing they
couldn't help us with
cause they were, they gave us the idea,
you need to give bonuses
to healthcare workers
because of the extra
mile they went, right.
They were dealing with
COVID situations and so on.
And we had to explain to them
that we asked our nurses
to take a cut in salary
so we could keep the institution afloat.
So everywhere else we were
able to learn from them,
but I think they were surprised
of the commitment of our
people and the mission
that they actually took
cuts in compensation
to be able to address the
challenges that faced us,
so yes, including Yale.
- Yeah, so I'll just wrap up really nice
and thoughtful session with a few words
first to say that we have the next event
with Dr. Tedros, from
WHO that is coming up
that's the next event in
the conversation series.
And then as we leave I think they will
sort of project the slide
so I would invite everyone
to connect there and
it's shaping up nicely
based on our discussion
with his team and his staff.
And it should be an interesting session,
but I will the last thing I would say
is that universities have
a unique role in combating
and preparing the world for
mass challenges like pandemics
because pandemics often
happen across generations.
And so universities survive corporations,
they survive governments
and sometimes the survive republics,
just as an example the
top eight corporations
in the US have their life
is the average life span
of the current topic is
approximately 60 years.
And Ivy League, the eight Ivy Leagues
have on average, I think,
close to 275 years old.
And so therefore there's
a unique responsibility
on universities and their faculty
and their students to learn the lessons
from these kinds of catastrophic events
and pass on to the next generation,
through our research, through our teaching
and sharing how we advise governments
how we handle these situations
both as institutions ourselves,
but also as incubators of some
of the best expertise available
for addressing these problems.
So to our students, no pressure,
but to our faculty that it's
a unique responsibility,
I hope we will live up to
going forward for generations.
So thank you for, to the panelists,
thank you for the engaged audience
we got a ton of questions I
couldn't get to all of them,
actually not even half of them,
but I really appreciate
everyone's participation.
- Thank you, Saad
- Thank you Saad
- Thank you.
Thank you very much.
- Nice to see everyone.
- Bye-bye
- Bye-bye.